>>> HELLO AND WELCOME TO
"CONNECT THE WORLD."
I'M FILLING IN FOR MY COLLEAGUE
BECKY ANDERSON.
WE'RE TRACKING TWO STORIES OUT
OF EQUIGYPT, AT LEAST 32 PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN KILLED WITH COLLIDING
TRAINS, DOZENS MORE INJURED.
THIS HAPPENED IN EGYPT EARLIER
ON FRIDAY.
THE ACCIDENT WAS CAUSED BY
SOMEONE PULLING AN EMERGENCY
BRAKE.
NOW EGYPT'S POOR RAIL WAY SYSTEM
IS NOTORIOUS FOR COLLISIONS, AS
WELL AS OTHER ACCIDENTS.
BEN WEEDERMAN JOINS US.
HORRIFIC PICTURES COMING INTO
US, BEN.
BRING US UP TO SPEED WITH WHAT
WE KNOW.
>> Reporter: YEAH, THIS IS THE
TRAIN, LINDA, LEADED TO
ALEXANDRIA, REALLY ONE OF THE
BUSIEST TRAIN LINES HERE IN
EGYPT AND OF COURSE, IT'S
FRIDAY, THE WEEKEND SO WE CAN
FAIRLY WELL ASSUME THAT THAT
TRAIN WAS FULL.
AT 11:42 LOCAL TIME, THAT'S
ABOUT FIVE HOURS AND 19 MINUTES
AGO.
SOMEBODY, ACCORDING TO THE
EGYPTIAN GOVERNMENT PULLED THE
EMERGENCY BRAKE AND CAUSED THIS
TRAIN TO STOP AND ANOTHER TRAIN
SLAMMED IT INTO IT FROM BEHIND
FROM THE PICTURES WE'VE SEEN
SEVERAL OF THE TRAIN WAGONS
PASSENGER TRAIN WAGONS WERE
THROWN OFF THE TRACKS AND THERE
ARE LOTS OF INJURIES.
NOW, THE LATEST IS AT LEAST 32
DEAD.
WE JUST HEARD THAT AT LEAST 91
INJURED AS WELL.
NOW THE PRIME MINISTER AND THE
PRESIDENT OF EGYPT HAVE BOTH
SAID THAT WHOEVER WAS
RESPONSIBLE WILL BE PUNISHED.
OBVIOUSLY.
AND BUT YES, AS YOU MENTIONED,
EGYPT HAS THE EGYPTIAN RAIL
SYSTEM HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
ACCIDENTS.
SOME OF THEM HORRIFIC, EVEN
WORSE THAN THIS ONE, IN FACT,
BUT YES, THIS OBVIOUSLY ADDS TO
THE HEADACHES OF -- AND
HEARTBREAK OF THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S ALREADY DEALING WITH THIS
PROBLEM IN THE CANAL.
LINDA?
>> IT CERTAINLY IS.
BEN, I'D LIKE YOU TO STICK
AROUND TO DISCUSS THAT STORY IN
JUST A MOMENT.
BEN WEDEMAN THERE.
WE'RE FOLLOWING THE BLOCK OF THE
CANAL.
THE OWNER OF THE GIANT CONTAINER
SHIP BLOCKING THE CANAL SAYS IT
MIGHT BE FREE AND FLOATING AGAIN
THIS WEEKEND.
NOW, THAT'S RATHER AN OPTIMISTIC
OUTLOOK SINCE ONE SALVAGE
COMPANY SAYS "THE EVER GIVEN "IS
STUCK ROCK SOLID.
IT'S BEEN STUCK SINCE TUESDAY
BRINGING ONE OF THE BUSIEST
WATERWAYS TO A STRETCHING HALT.
NO SMALL TASK DISLODGING THIS
MASSIVE VESSEL.
MORE THAN 15,000 CUBIC METERS OF
SAND HAVE TO BE REMOVED TO GET
IT OUT.
GIANT MACHINES HAVE BEEN WORKING
AROUND THE CLOCK TO MOVE THE
SAND AND THE MUD AND TAKE A LOOK
AT THIS PHOTO THAT WE'VE GOT
DOZENS OF SHIPS IN THE CANAL
WHEN THE "EVER GIVEN" GOT STUCK
AND THEY ARE JUST WAITING.
OTHER SHIPS ARE TAKING OTHER
ROUTES THAT ADDS TIME AND MONEY
TO EVERY OTHER SHIPMENT.
WE'RE COVERING THIS STORY FROM
EVERY OTHER ANGLE.
ABU DHABI AND BEN WEDEMAN IS
JOINING US FROM CAIRO.
JOHN, I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE
BACKLOG BECAUSE THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF SHIPS, OBVIOUSLY,
WAITING TO GET THROUGH AND THE
DESIRE TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN
QUICKLY.
JUST BRING US UP TO SPEED WITH
WHAT THE CANAL AUTHORITY IS
SAYING WITH PROGRESS.
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO TURN THE
TIDE AFTER A SLOW START IN THE
FIRST TWO DAYS AFTER THIS
OPERATION.
THE CANAL AUTHORITY IS GIVING
GUIDANCE IT HAS TARGET TO REACH
20,000 CUBIC METERS OF SAND AND
MUD TO DRUDGE OUT IN A SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME AND THEY ARE
SAYING THEY ARE 87% THERE.
I FIND IT RIGHT BUT THEY ARE
CAUTIOUS SUGGESTING NO TIMELINE
AT THIS STAGE OF THE GAME AND
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE HUNDREDS OF
SHIPS.
IN FACT, THE LIST IS GROWING
LONGER, LINDA.
THE LATEST UPDATE FROM 10:00
A.M. THIS MORNING.
IT CROSSED FROM 200 TO 239 AND
THE DATA COLLECTION GROUP AND
ANALYSIS GROUP SUGGESTED WE'RE
STARTING TO SEE ANOTHER 100
ARRIVE BY THE END OF BUSINESS ON
SUNDAY IF THIS IS NOT SOLVED.
YOU TALK ABOUT SHIPS REROUTING.
WE SEE THIS IN THE EARLY STAGES
RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE A COUNT OF CONTAINER AND
ENERGY VESSELS, 11 GOING
EASTBOUND AND WESTBOUND EVEN IF
IT WILL TAKE LONGER TO GO AROUND
THE CAPE OF GOOD HOPE INTO
AFRICA AND THE UNITED STATES.
THEY WILL BE CUTTING THEIR
LOSSES BY TAKING ACTION NOW.
WHAT IS GLOBAL COMMERCE?
DOES THIS ARTERY MEAN?
WE TRY TO PUT THIS IN REAL
NUMBERS TO GIVE A SENSE OF THE
VALUE OF THE GOODS PASSING
THROUGH.
ACCORDING TO LLOYD'S LIST,
THAT'S $10 BILLION A DAY GOING
THROUGH THE CANAL ALONE.
THE VALUE OF THE GOODS PASSING
THROUGH, $400 MILLION PER HOUR.
SO THIS WOULD HAVE AN INCREDIBLE
IMPACT IN TERMS OF COMMERCE.
PEOPLE KEEP TEXTING AND ASKING
THE INFLUENCE OF GROWTH.
NOTHING YET.
WE'RE FOUR DAYS INTO IT.
SPILLS INTO A SECOND AND THIRD
WEEK, THAT CHANGES THE GAME.
THEY ARE TRYING TO AVOID THAT BY
STEPPING UP THE DRUDGING HERE.
>> INCREDIBLE FIGURES YOU'RE
THROWING OUT AS 400 -- I THINK
YOU SAID $10 BILLION.
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING, I
WANT TO GO TO BEN WEDEMAN WITH
ALL OF THIS BECAUSE AS WE'VE
DISCUSSED, THIS SHIPPING ROUTE
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR 10 TO 12% OF
GLOBAL TRADE.
JUST BRING US UP TO SPEED WITH
WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE IN TERMS
OF THE RAMIFICATIONS WE'RE GOING
TO SEE IF THIS DRAGS ON NOT JUST
FOR DAYS BUT POTENTIALLY WEEKS.
>> WELL, IF WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EG
EGYPT, THEY GET $5.6 BILLION A
YEAR, THEY DID LAST YEAR AT
LEAST IN REVENUES FROM THE SUEZ
CANAL AND PUTS THEM ON THE MAP
FOR GLOBAL TRADE AND THEREFORE,
THERE IS A LOT OF STAKE IF YOU
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE FACT THAT
WITH THE SHRINKING POLAR ICECAP,
THERE ARE NEW ROUTES BEING
LOOKED AT.
THE EGYPTIANS SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY IN THE LAST FEW YEARS
TRYING TO UPGRADE AND EXPAND THE
SUEZ CANAL AND THIS IS QUITE A
TASK BECAUSE WE'RE SEEING THAT
SHIPS ARE GETTING BIGGER AND
BIGGER.
THE EVER"EVER GIVEN" IS ONE OF
LARGEST CONTAINER SHIPS ON
EARTH.
SINCE 1956 THE WIDTH OF THE SUEZ
CANAL HAS BEEN DOUBLED BUT EVEN
THAT ISN'T ENOUGH TO AVOID THIS
KIND OF VERY EXPENSIVE AND
FRANKLY, EMBARRASSING PROBLEM.
>> CERTAINLY EMBARRASSING.
BEN WEDEMAN.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO JOHN
BECAUSE AS FAR AS WE UNDERSTAND,
HIGH WINDS PLAYED A ROLE IN
CAUSING THIS INCIDENT.
DOES MOTHER NATURE HAVE A ROLE
IN THE EFFORT TO FREE IT?
>> THAT'S WHAT THE SHIPPING
INDUSTRY IS HOPING FOR, LINDA.
LET COVER OFF THE SING THE
SOURCE OF THE CHALLENGE FOR THE
"EVER GIVEN."
WAS IT THE VERACITY OF STAND
STORM THAT CAUSED THE PROBLEM?
THERE IS A HUGE DEBATE I'M
LISTENING TO THAT SAYS IT SEEMS
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE NOT TO HAVE
ANOTHER FEATURE INVOLVED, AN
ENGINE CHALLENGE BUT THAT'S LEFT
TO THE COMMUNITY NOT BEEN
DETERMINED THERE IS STILL AN
INVESTIGATION TAKING PLACE.
NOW, REGARDS TO MOTHER NATURE'S
ROLE THIS WEEKEND, I'VE HAD TWO
SHIPPING EXECUTIVES TELL ME IN
THE LAST 24 HOURS, LOOK AT THE
TIDE REPORTS.
I SAID OKAY, WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
IT SAID IT HIGH TIDE, A SEASONAL
HIGH TIDE ON SUNDAY, THE 28th IN
THE SUEZ CANAL.
I WON'T SAY THIS WILL BE THE
PROBLEM SOLVER.
IT CAN BE THE ASSISTANCE FOR ALL
THAT DRUDGING THAT COMES THROUGH
AND THE BEST CHANCE FOR THEM TO
REFLOAT THE VESSEL, ACCORDING TO
THE SOURCES I'M SPEAKING TO.
BUT WE'RE GETTING SOME VERY
MIXED SIGNALS AND YOU MENTIONED
THIS IN THE LEAD IN.
WE HAVE A JAPANESE SHIP OWNER
SUGGESTING IT WILL BE REFLOATED
ON SATURDAY EVENING.
THAT SEEMS LIKE AN ACCELERATED
TIMELINE AND ONE OF THE TOUCH
SALVAGE COMPANIES, THE CEO VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD OVER THE LAST 48
HOURS SAYS THIS IS A QUOTE, HE
SAYS THAT HE THINKS THAT SHIP IS
STUCK ROCK SOLID AND NOT GOING
ANYWHERE FAST, EVEN THOUGH WE
SEE DRUDGING NUMBERS GOING UP.
IMPRESSIVE IN TERMS OF PROGRESS
NOW BUT A SPLIT DECISION WHETHER
THIS WILL HAPPEN OVER THE
WEEKEND OR NOT, AND RIGHT NOW,
THE CANAL AUTHORITY IS NOT
WILLING TO GIVE ANY GUIDANCE
WHATSOEVER.
SO IT'S INTERESTING WHAT WE'RE
SEEING NOW IS SOME SHIPS LEAVING
THE AREA AT THE SAME TIME NOT
WANTING TO GET STUCK IN